started welcome back everyone to the
fourth day of uh this boot camp it looks
like even the weather is back to normal
today um so so we have Jonathan telling
us uh more about um problemistic and
comol methods in coding
Theory thank you okay um yeah so uh we
left with a cliffhanger yesterday so
let's recall where we
were um okay so we started definition of
uh a code that we say is locally similar
to a random linear code so what does it
mean uh to be locally similar to a code
to random linear code of
R so okay so we have this random code
emble okay so we should think of c as a
random code uh taken by some other
distribution not a random linear code
usually a more structured
distribution um and then we can ask uh
for a given uh coule of code
uh what's the probability that c
contains all of them and we say uh that
c is locally similar to a random linear
code if for any tupple uh this
probability uh
is bounded from Okay so yesterday we
said similar but actually bounded from
above is enough for what we're trying to
do and this is gonna somewhat matter
today um so it's going to be bounded
from above by the
probability that uh the same tle uh
belongs to random linear code okay which
is just this exponential thing this
negative exponential thing in the
dimension of the T okay and the theorem
that we saw and this comes from the
threshold
characterization uh for local properties
of random linear
codes uh we saw that if we have some
random linear code emble that's locally
similar to random linear code of rate
R
um then it achieves all the monotone
local and symmetric properties that we
expect to achieve by random linear code
okay so any monotone local and symmetric
property that a random linear code
achieves uh this random emble would also
achieve now another thing I added that
we didn't have yesterday is that we
actually like the locality here is
actually going to be a parameter okay so
I'm talking about like K being K locally
uh uh uh similar to random ler code
means that this holds for tles of of up
to K
uh uh vectors okay and then what we're
going to get uh the larger K is the more
similar the more similar we are to
random line your code uh and then here
we're going to get uh more properties
because we're going to get up to this
locality so for example you can think of
the locality is the list size for listed
coding okay um okay
nice um and I want to warm up by showing
you a certain uh uh Ensemble which is
very well known or well it's a variant
of a very well-known emble for which
it's pretty easy to prove uh uh this
local similarity to random linear code
so I talk about the Wen craft Ensemble
so this is used uh in the construction
of uh well I think it's the first known
construction to like the explicit
construction of uh codes uh UST and
codes uh so this is a part of that
construction so okay so what's the I'm
going to talk about the generalized
wizcraft emble but first let's just uh
recall what is the Wen craft emble
itself um so we think about uh this is
going to be uh a code of rate one2 and
we're going to think about uh words of
length n which are divided into two
parts each size M okay
and the way these words work is as
follows so we have we're going to uh
encode elements of the
field of size 2 to the m naturally into
just sequences of M bits okay and what's
a code word so we need to sample some
random Alpha from the field fq okay
where Q is uh sorry I didn't write that
Q is 2 to DM okay so I'm I'm I'm
sampling some Alpha from The Big Field
from the field F2 to DM and then the
code words are going to be all the words
of the
form uh it's going to be pairs of x and
then this Alpha time x okay and I'm
going to encode them into M bits and M
bits so the randomness comes from the
sampling of
alpha
um and you can already see that this is
less random than random linear code
because for random linear code I need
roughly N squared random bits here I
only need around n random bits to sample
an element from this field okay so it's
plus um and I get the this code of
rate2 okay and this code is one locally
similar to a random linear code of of
similar
rate why um okay so to prove one local
similarity I just need to show you that
if I take a topple of one vector or just
a vector then the probability that it's
contained in the Wen craft code is
roughly the same as it would be in a
random linear code which should be like
2 to Theus n/ two okay and this is
really the why because take some y uh
some uh um take some string Y and ask
what's the probab we want to ask what's
the probability that this is contained
in the W Craft emble what why can be we
think of why as an encoding of two uh uh
uh elements of the field so there's only
one way to write y as encoding of X and
then well the second uh the second field
element would need to be like some beta
times x okay and then the only way for
this word y to be contained in Los craft
symble is if Alpha equals beta which
which happens with probability exactly 2
to Theus M which is exactly 2us n over
two okay so this is uh one equ this is
one locally similar to random linear
code which is a very strange way to
State a fact that you probably already
known uh if you took uh uh uh coding
class that mentioned
this um okay so now the corollary for
which we really don't need this whole
sophisticated Machinery of the threshold
of random linear code but we can use it
if we want so the C would be that the
wraft emble achieves the same one local
properties as a random linear code of
rate one2 uh for example what's a one
local property so the minimal weight is
a one local property right it's it's a
you just need uh to to to show that uh a
code has weight less than something I
only need to show you one R for linear
code I only need to show you one bad
witness which is a short word okay so in
particular achieves the the random could
Achi the GV Bound for distance so this
also achieves the GV Bound for distance
okay how do we generalize
this so we do the same thing but instead
of Pi picking a random Alpha we're going
to pick a random polom over the field of
the at most K and then our code words
instead of taking X and alpha x I'm
going to take X and this polom applied
to X okay and I'm not going to prove
this claim but you can easily prove it
using exactly the same sort of logic
okay we just need the fact
that uh a polinomial of degree at most K
is defined explicitly is uniquely
defined by any K values right uh and
that's exactly going to mean uh that any
uh kuple is going
to uh belong to this code with
probability it's
most um well exactly what we expect in
random linear
code so these codes are K random K
locally similar to a random L code of
rate half and in particular they achieve
for example the list decoding GV bound
uh that's achieved by random linear
codes so this is already a nice and
simple uh derandomization result uh that
we get from the this is actually I think
this is not I think this doesn't appear
any paper but it's like this nice to
example it's it already gives us um
codes that
achieve um the list decoding GV bound um
with n Randomness instead of n
squ okay so now um let's go to a more uh
um a more deep deeper
result uh um okay so I'm going to
explain what like there a few Notions
here that need to be explained but uh
the theorem says as follows let D be a
low bias code low bias just means so you
can just think I'm only going to Define
it say in the case of the in the binary
case so low by just means that you have
good distance but you also have good
distance from the uh not just from the
all zeros uh uh okay you're not just far
from the all zeros word but so far from
the old ones word okay so in other words
all the weights of the code words other
than the zero code word lie very close
to2 these are in particular you should
think of d as having very low rates so
that it can have it can have this
property of like having very low bias
okay uh so these some low rate code
which has low bias um and then what we
do is we randomly punctuate which I'm
going to Define exactly but just think
of like taking C to be um the
coordinates of c are going going to be
randomly
sampled of D um then we're saying so
this is a work with venat we're saying
that uh C is going to be uh locally
similar and I'm not going to go into the
exact dependence of K on the parameters
here uh but C is going to be locally
similar to a random linear code
okay
and one caveat for this fum I'm going to
talk about like what ex what this can be
used for uh uh
but one caveat is this this we're going
to see why this can requires us to have
a constant alphabet
size um so for example this cannot be
used uh to argue about uh what we wanted
the most uh which is uh read Solon
codes um because randomly punctured if
you take this is going to be something
that will be discussed at length at the
at the later part of this lecture but if
you take
uh the read Solon code with the full
evaluation set that's evaluated on the
whole field and you randomly puncture it
you get a read Solomon code uh evaluated
on some random set and one motivation
for studying this was exactly so that we
can study these sorts of read solmon
codes over random
sets um and then show that they are
locally similar to random linear codes
so for example CH ver list decodability
uh the problem is really uh that this is
not going to work explicitly using the
spum because the SP needs the alphabet
size to be small where uh uh read suon
codes needs the alphabets to be at least
n okay so before explaining going deeper
into this spum I'll just mention that uh
this random puncturing was recently uh
somewhat d randomized by Potterman and
Pine in a paper that will be uh
presented in itcs on here on Wednesday I
think
right
okay so let's uh Define puncturing uh
more precisely so puncturing is the
operation by which we take a code so
again we think of D is some low R and
rather long
code of length M and we create from it a
new code which is much shorter okay of
length code C of length n where n is
going to be uh smaller than
n
um right so we just
pick if these are the code words of D
then just the code words of c are going
to be the Cod of D minus or like we just
choose certain coordinates and throw off
the rest you should think of most of
these columns as being red and only a
few being blue okay so we keep only a
small portion of the
Coes
um okay and if we create C at random by
picking the coordinates at random from
here then we say that c is a random
puncturing of the code D now one
motivation or one intuition for what
we're doing here is the observation that
a random linear code itself can be seen
as a random puncturing so if we take D
to be the adomar code which is
exponentially long in N okay so it's
very very very long
code um then
um and and we Rand puncture it then what
we get is exactly random linear
code um the thing is that this is a
rather random process because the admr
code is such a long code so we need a
lot of bits to sample from it uh now if
you could start from a shorter code here
then you'd get something with more
structure because you know presumably
some structure from the top code from d
goes goes over to C for example uh if D
is a read solmon code um then C would
also be a read code of a random set
which still has a lot of algebraic
structure uh there's a case where this
where our fum is actually applicable uh
so if we take D to be a dual bch code
and these are codes with uh um with
constant alphabets that do have low bias
uh then we get again some of the
algebraic structure of the Dual bch code
uh in C as well so uh uh so this gives
us uh um so so so this P would apply to
certain more structured analogs of
random linear
codes yeah so I'm saying here for
example that read Solon code can be seen
Rand read somee random valuations that
can be seen as such a puncture
okay um okay sorry what our Fe is going
to say is that as long as this code has
low bias then this code is uh uh list
decodable and all the nice stuff we can
get from randomly codes this code is
going to be similar to randomly
code um so let's for now on we're going
to focus for this the we're going to
focus just in the binary case this is
going to work similarly for any constant
size um yeah so so the FM says the
following suppose that every uh word in
VI has close weight close to normalized
weight close to half so again for the
Adar code it's going to be exactly half
and this is you can't get weight exactly
half with a code less uh not as long
like which is shorter than had more code
but you can get close you can get get
with much much shorter codes uh for
example uh uh tashma codes uh which only
require uh length linear rather than
exponential in N can get you very very
close uh to uh perfectly like so so
admer codee has zero bias but attachment
code would have like very small Epsilon
bias with much much shorter
code uh or say take a dual bch code and
then the theor is that if we do this
operation in such a code D see is going
to be locally similar to random near
code and then C is list the Cod this
recover B the ROM
code okay I want to quickly give you an
idea of how this is
proven
okay so we're going to do a
comparison between a random linear
code and our code C which is a
puncturing of D okay so we have these
are going to be all the code roots of
D and yeah we have a puncturing of them
and then we get this new code
C and
then this is going to be the adomar code
and if Rand randomly punctuate then we
get a random linear
code so we can really think of so this
operation is happening side by side here
we puncture D we get C here we puncture
ad or code we get randomly air code and
now we need to show that a toule of code
words
appears here and here with roughly the
same probability so let's fix a tppo the
same
tppo um in both cases okay so here I
fixed L Plus
one code words and here I'm fixing the
same l+1 code words and I want to know
what's the probability that these code
words appear here versus what's the
probability that they appear
here now how would I do that I can
take
[Music]
um I can take uh um okay we're going to
do okay we're going to say the following
uh the probability of getting getting
like this tle of code words so this
tople of code words can be born this is
L plus1 code words but it can be born
from any l+1 code words here so we're
going to do we're going to sum over all
the L plus1 tles of code words here and
for each one this is this is Justified
again this is just a proof sketch but
for each tle here uh we just want to
compute the probability that this tle is
going to yield this tle here okay so
what does this depend on okay and now I
have a specific topple of L plus1 code
wordss here and I want to know what the
probability that it gives us
this
so This depends only so the arrows here
can be a bit confusing like because I
because I put them they don't intersect
but they don't cross but you should
think of the arrows as they can also
cross with the same probability okay you
should just think of every column here
is being Chosen uniformly and
independently at random from The Columns
here
so the
probability of getting a certain toule
of code words here depends solely on one
thing it only depends on the column
distribution of this and similarly here
okay the probability of getting this tle
here depends solely on the column
distribution of this okay so we end up
with the following thing we have L plus
one code words here and L plus1 code
words here and we want to show that some
probability that depends on the column
distribution of these
columns um happens so this distri so
This probability that depends on this
column
distribution happens with similar
probability to this something here that
depends only on this column
distribution thus what we really want to
show is that for these code wordss the
distribution of these columns is similar
to the distribution of
cols so this is what the all reduces to
just like looking at tles of code words
in the mother codes okay in the anomer
code versus some other code and
comparing the column distribution the
empirical column distributions of the
columns uh that we have
here
okay now for the admr
code the column distribution is uniform
that's one way to characterize the Adar
code that if you take um linearly
independent code words then the column
distribution is exactly
uniform so really what we want is to
show that here the column distribution
is close to
uniform and this is what's left here uh
is just doing this via for analysis so
so
um if you okay so so I'm not gonna
actually go into the free analysis I'm
gonna say a few hints for uh whoever uh
is fluent in this in sort of
arguments um that if you look at this
distribution and think of it as some
function then okay the the distribution
itself so it's a function over F2 to the
L plus one yes um B should be L plus one
on the bottom right there right distri H
oh I wrote B yeah it should be L plus
one yeah thanks um
can you tell me that
later I'll fix it for the
yeah
um yeah so so okay so just think of a
function uh of this distribution as a
function then um it's uh Foria
coefficients are determined exactly by
the weights of linear combinations of
these words now the linear combinations
are themselves words in the code so they
are all of low bias so all the for
coefficients are close to zero okay so
here all the for all the non-rival for
coefficients are zero and here they all
close to zero and so the distributions
are close in verier uh uh uh in ver
forier coefficients so they're also
close um uh so we're also close uh in
the prime
um in the prime base
um now if you followed this argument
then you can also see why we need
constant alphabet size uh because this
transition from similarity in the frea
basis to uh uh similarity and the Primal
basis uh involves uh hit of the
size of the domain so in the binary case
the size of the domain would be like 2
to the L plus one which is a constant
because we think of L as being a
constant in these uh
in um but uh if the AL Al size is q and
that would be a hit of Q to the l+ one
and where Q starts being large like for
you think of Q is being L as being n
when this is something that's completely
unmanageable
okay um great okay so that was this
theorum and this is um so for example
it's gonna it gives us that again that
we can you know it gives us certain
randomizations random linear codes it
says that puncturing many other more
structured codes uh gives other
structured codes gives us some nice
structured uh P randomly like the
randomly punctured codes also have some
structure and they are locally similar
to random linear code so they have all
the the uh list decoding probabil
properties uh which is very nice uh so
this exemplifies the basic method uh but
I promis that I'm going to talk to you
about read Solon codes at some point so
we're getting there in order to do that
I first want to have a discussion about
all the drawback backs of the method I
described uh in the last hour and a half
of my talks yesterday and today so just
like to say what method I'm talking
about I'm talking about the method where
we use the fesal theorem random linear
codes um to show that another code emble
is similar to uh to uh that another
codem has this uh low similarity
property okay to random near code and US
say something about its list
decodability and this recoverability so
what are the drawbacks of this method
there are quite a few I listed
them
okay so first locality is
necessary um so maybe I should say I
should apologize um so I have a friend
who uh came to me yesterday and told me
that uh when I uh spoke about this uh
yesterday
um but and I presented the problem I I I
presented list decodability as if I said
yeah well L is obviously a constant and
list recoverability which is I guess
even worse um
um it's a worst mistake on my part I
presented the list
recoverability uh scenario is if L is
always a constant and this is not true
uh there are many many interesting and
important questions especially to the
pseudo Randomness Community which I have
deeply hurt uh that uh uh involve L
being large um no yeah I I was okay the
there really are very important
questions yeah I mean I'm even um I'm
even thinking about some of them so so
yeah I should I should have said that so
for example here's a question that this
method cannot address um so just
consider a random your code um and think
about list
recoverability where we have
combinatorial rectangles okay so this is
like GNA be some big field fq and think
of commerial rectangles uh where in each
uh coordinate we get Q over two
letters um so then a random rectangle
has roughly Q to the RN is the size of
the code and 2 to the minus n is the
probability that random word appears in
the rectangle so in a random
rectangle uh we expect Q to the RN * 2
to the minus n code words and if Q is
large enough and R is not very small
then this is a an exponentially large
number okay uh because qdn is going to
win over two to minus n uh so this is
exponential large number and then the
question is uh what's the probability
like can we show that with high
probability uh the rectangle the
combinatorial rectangle that has
uh uh the most uh code words does not
deviate from the expectation by more of
than an Epsilon fraction okay so this is
um Prett natural problem that we don't
know how to solve and the reason this
question that this method uh is useless
against it is because the locality here
is this is not local right like to show
you uh to show you at least naively to
show you that a rectangle does not the
code does not satisfy this property I
mean to show you this number of code
words okay so this is not a local
witness um cool so this is an open
problem like this is also this is the
drawback session is also like an open
problem session okay it's a it's a
combination of the two um next okay
so this method can only deal with what I
term Sigma One Properties you can think
of this as NP or maybe Co NP properties
what do I mean by that uh so to show
show you that a
code um is not list
decodable with constant L I just need to
show you a short
witness okay um so this would be like Co
andp right like list the code abilities
like o andp in order to I can easily
convince you with a small witness that
the code does not have this property
okay uh and these are properties that in
logic are called Sigma 1 or Pi 1 these
are properties that are only that you
only need one quantifier to define the
property um so it's like not being low
list decodable is equivalent to there
exists a witness such that something
which is easily ver verified but of
course sometimes we want to talk about
uh properties that are not of this form
uh so one I think like the most
wellknown example is if uh uh the so
thinking about stochastic channels
usually leads to um properties that have
more than one um quantifier here I'm
going to give a different example uh
which is kind of like a toy it's not a
toy problem because I I don't know how
to solve it but it it is a problem that
I came up with in thinking about uh what
would generalize the notion of Sigma one
properties for uh this Viewpoint uh that
we have on say random linear codes so
say that a code
C is row L covering covering the
covering is okay so these are covering
codes generally a row covering code uh
is a code in which which covers the
space with balls of uh radius row okay
so you put a ball of radius row around
each code word and uh if and and you say
that the code is row covering if this
covers the entire space the entire the
entirety of F2 to the end um and and
note that here it's easier to be usually
we we're used to like write like we're
used to to a lower rate giving us Better
communial Properties here it's the
opposite here uh it's easier to be
covering if your rate is higher uh right
because you have more code words to
cover with um so we said that the code
is row L
covering this is if I remember correctly
I didn't like I don't think I defined it
I think this this is something that has
been studied I think it even
interests uh some people in certain more
applied um Fields uh so we said that the
code is Royal covering if every X in F2
to the N is very close to at least L
code word so in other words every uh uh
word in the domain needs to be covered
not by one but by L
balls um okay and then the question is
uh you know what's the rate threshold
here uh what for what rates can we
expect Ro the rural covering property to
hold uh uh for a random linear code the
thing is that this is not a signal one
property okay I don't I don't know uh
Witnesses for uh easily verifiable
Witnesses here uh to why because to
State this property right what does it
mean to be royal covering it means that
for
all elements in F22 DM there
exist L code words that cover them okay
so we switch quantifiers when we switch
quantifiers it becomes the way I just uh
described it it's what's called a pi 2
property it's a okay Sigma 2 or Pi 2 are
when we have both quantifiers Pi is when
we start from for all and sigma is when
we start from for from exists okay so it
is interesting if we can somehow
generalize this
method um to uh you know more
complicated properties in terms of in in
in this in these logical terms this is
somehow um anales to you know thinking
about the for example the polinomial
hierarchy in
complexity okay
um another another drawback is that
being
locally question is it the answer know
just
random
I my guess is that yes but I didn't like
I didn't think about it uh it's this is
a question I thought about very little I
give it mostly as a sort of uh
illustration
for uh what sort of uh like like a
natural property that that's uh pi two
but I really I I really haven't
seriously thought about this question I
also haven't like seriously researched
what's no except that I don't I I am
pretty convinced that the the answer to
this specific question is right now not
known but I don't know if it's because
no one seriously tried to solve it or is
like is it really difficult my guess is
that it is somewhat difficult L is one
this is the covering radius so one way
the answer to this might be known is
that once you get get one code word
maybe you actually get lots of code
words yeah that's no ofation so I I
think I saw somewhere um well okay I'm
speculating because I think I I read
somewhere that this is not the way it
works but um I'm not sure right now yeah
definely yes yes
um
okay um okay next thing is that so we
think of right so so so we thought these
examples that I showed uh um for example
these randomly punctured codes and the
generalized wraft emble I I said that
they some somewhat der
randomize
uh they some der randomize random
codes
um so yeah so we show we we say that any
code which has this local similarity
property okay again that tles appear in
C with the same probability that they
would appear in random your code so
these topples
uh so these codes are uh local is are
what we call locally similar to random
linear code the problem is that these
codes must be random themselves like
you're not gonna right we're not going
to get uh we're not going to get a
deterministic code to satisfy this and
moreover you can't satisfy this property
with less than order of n random
bits uh why because to get you know to
get something to appear in the code with
probability
2us 1 -
RN so there needs to be an event that
happens with probability 2 to the minus
one minus
RN and this is a res this
resolution this this is uh this
resolution this is too fine grained to
happen if you don't have n random bits
right like just like the log of this is
order of n well Min like minus of log of
this is order of n so you can't get this
s of probability uh with uh less of an
order of
n sorry and yeah I'm thinking okay sorry
yeah I I uh uh I again assumed that the
locality is uh is a constant yeah so
this would be like order of n times the
locality for what you really
want um so
this um
completely this means that we're not
going to Der randomize using just this
method um below this order of n
threshold and this open problem actually
is you know it's a much more General
open problem than just uh concerning
this the what the the question I showed
about random linear codes but
generally
this has to do I believe with the
fact that we know how to achieve just
like to construct codes that achieved
the Gilbert vov bound with order of n
random bits but we don't know how to go
below that and
being slightly careful here maybe we
know how to get like order of n over
some log log n Bits or something like
that I'm not sure but but essentially we
don't know how to go along the four door
fan random bit threshold for uh the G
and it's it's kind of for similar
reasons the way we know to prove that
something satisfies the Gilbert the
original Gilbert okay the one for
distance
the way we know how to uh uh how to
prove this bound is exactly is basically
is only by showing that the probability
of a given code
word is this okay and whenever we try to
go this way we're not going to get
better than order of and
Randomness okay and the last drawback of
this method and this is what we're going
to talk about for the rest of these
talks is that in the method I showed the
alphabet cannot be
large um right
so I I talked about this a bit yesterday
but uh I'll try to recap quickly
so I recall that in this method we do a
union
bound over all the possible row
distributions for our Matrix in F2 to
the L plus one but whatever um right and
we send us okay how many row
distributions are there uh very roughly
n to the 2 to the L this is uh an upper
estimation but it's not very uh is this
question h no it looks like oh you're
doing this I thought you're my
thoughtful face ah
okay yeah I don't know trying to figure
out what this means
uh okay uh yeah okay so we need to Union
bound Over N to the two to the L
distributions which is fine because this
is a tiny number this is a polinomial in
n
uh but for General Q this number is
going to be n to the Q to the L and and
really right and then like you know if
for example you take Q to be n which is
like Q needs to be at least n for read
Solon codes then you get like n to the N
to the L types so this is something
horribly exponential in n and then Union
bounding over this um like is is going
to kill you um there's maybe another
intuition I can give here is that so in
this case right like you have what is
this distribution you drop N Balls into
two tol bins and N is if L is constant
then n is much larger than 2 todl so you
know every bin is going to have some
fraction of the balls and this is stuff
that we know how to work with here you
have q to the L bins so for example
think of n to the L bills n to the L
bins and just end balls
so most uh like you're probably just
going to have you know most of the bins
are going to end up empty and some of
them are going to have one ball so
remembering the distribution is just
like it doesn't really lose information
like you know like it tells you exact
when you remember exactly what are the
full bins and what are the empty bins
when it pretty much tells you you know
up to this reordering of the Matrix
which is not uh uh which is not the big
part of the
uh of the number of matrices here it
doesn't really forget enough okay and
the whole idea of remembering just the
distributions is that you forget enough
information that you can do a union
bound okay so so this really doesn't
work here so you need another framework
um for
this and then really the question is is
there any hope of reasoning about for
example read salmon codes Q where Q
needs to be at least M with this
method and the answer is that not with
this method but with
some analogous and properly suited
method okay uh so just to recap what's
the read Solon codes code because from
now on we're going to talk be talking
about them all the time so you pick some
alphabet q and you feel like your your
alphabet size is is Q so you think of
the field fq you pick a rank uh
k um and you choose some subset s of fq
to be your evaluation set and then your
code words are just evaluations of pooms
each code word is a polinomial of degree
less than K Over the field and the code
words are the evaluations of this
polinomial um over s we denote this code
by RS read Solomon with evaluation set s
and degree k um and and right so this
code has Dimension K and its length is
just n which is the size of s so the
rate is K Over N uh and we note that
since s is a subset of fq um and N is
the size of s then we must it must hold
that n is at
most um okay so these are read solmon
codes maybe I should State one more
thing so so for read solmon codes we
have the obvious like one obvious choice
of s is just to take the entire the
entirety of fq okay
um and that's called sometimes the full
read salmon code where the evaluation we
evaluate over everything and what we're
mostly going to concentrate on is the
case where s is chosen CH is a smaller
set of size n which is sample at random
from and these are we're going to call
these random read Solon codes okay
random read Solon codes is short for
read Solon codes or the evaluation set
is
random okay um and then want to know do
for exist read Solon codes that achieve
the list decoding bound the list
decoding GV bound and also if exist if
they exist how large does q need to be
uh we generally want the field size to
be as small as possible relative to the
length Okay
so this question
was quite uh extensively researched uh
including by
some of the people in this
room um and all okay
so
there's there's one notable work about
read the full read Solon code that I
didn't mention here the reason I didn't
mention it here is that it's a negative
result okay it shows that in some
parameter regime uh the full read
Solomon code does not achieve list
decoding capacity and these are all
positive results
about um the random read Solon code okay
so
these um I mean this one I think re wers
I think is 2014 or something like that
uh is um I never know like whether to
right like whether to think about the
year it was uploaded to archive or the
year it was published or yeah uh it's
hard to follow sometimes um and then all
of these I think are starting from 2020
all the way to less than a year ago so
so this is all uh really recent stuff
um and there's really a buildup like if
you follow these works you can really
see a buildup of many uh Notions that uh
are useful uh that turn out to be useful
and then like increasingly more
sophisticated techniques to work with
them and most recently uh there have
been positive and
answers to the question I gave before
okay so it shows that random read Solon
codes achieve the list decoding GV bound
and these okay so this was shown by B
GOI and mam but this is for uh
exponentially large
field then go and
Jang am I okay okay
H I know the feeling of like just like
being used to people butchering your
name just like oh yeah it's
fine uh sorry for that so uh yeah so so
uh they took uh the field size down to
quadratic in end and then we have uh
Omar vut and Ray Lee which uh took this
down
to
linear um and also say that list
recovery is also being researched
but uh he Cod and it's also very
interesting thing we just know less
about it so this is just to recap about
like the recent uh interesting results
now I'm going to focus in this result
which is the state-ofthe-art
um yeah I'm gonna do okay so I'm gonna
do something
um so here's the
thing I have uh with two students um
uh um Matan Levy and nikaya we have a
certain work which in particular Rec
covers this result by some other method
and also relies on Notions from this
work so it's not uh you know um and I
kind of debated on what exactly to show
because
uh okay so so I really I really think
that uh this work uh this AGL really
relies on a certain types framework even
though I I don't know if you guys see it
like that but I when I read it I
certainly think of it as as rep as
having some types
framework uh and our work has this types
framework put there very
explicitly and I'm going to present a
sort of mish mash of uh my view of this
and the
AGL uh view of this and we're going to
be talking about essentially how to show
that random read soling codes
um achieve uh the list decoding GV
bounds
um I also mention
that until this work we didn't
know that random linear
codes um for large Q achieve the least
decoding GV bound so this this work this
AGL also shows that uh and kind of
interestingly there's somewhat a partial
reduction in in AGL from like in the
opposite direction to what I showed you
so far very like what the the way to
show that uh random linear codes achieve
the list decoding GB bound uh
relies on uh on a theorem about read
solement code so it's the opposite of
what I show I showed you so far uh in
our work uh that's not the case so we
independently show in a more Elementary
way that random linear codes achieve the
coding GV bound and then we show uh a
reduction from that to read Solon code
so in our work it's it's really uh uh a
reduction from random Cod to read Sol
codes which is the more this is the
direction I've been trying to sell you
so far uh okay uh in these
talks okay so so we'll start getting
into the details and then I'll try to
give some sort of uh map to what's going
on okay so the first thing is
that as I explained before when Q is
large the types framework that I showed
is just um inadequate okay um because
the row distribution of a like
remembering okay so think as let's give
the let's recall what what the type the
types framework does so we have a which
is a witness Matrix okay this is a this
Matrix is a witness to the it's a what
we call a row clustered Matrix okay it's
a witness to the fact that a code
containing these
columns is not less
decodable and in the types framework uh
we want to do Union bounds over such
matrices we want to show that such a
matrix is unlikely in our code so we
want to do Union bound over them and in
order to do Union bound we need to uh
divide them into classes sometimes we
call these classes typ types so we
divide the U the bad matrices the the
witness matrices into types and as I
showed uh remembering the row
distribution of this Matrix a now uh
contains too much information there's
too many types it's too fine grain we
need to forget more on the other hand we
still need to retain the relevant
information so that we can bound the
probability that a code actually
contains Matrix of the given time okay
that's the tradeoff you need types that
remember the least amount of information
that still allows you to
to um to uh give some meaningful bound
on the probability of a code containing
such a
matrix okay
and the main
um the main uh uh um uh um idea that we
need here is that for a given Row in
this Matrix
I'm not really going to
Care what's the letter here and what's
the letter here and what's the letter
here and what's the letter here I'm only
going to care for each given row here
about uh the
relationship between the letters in the
given row so only going to care about
identities so formally uh with each row
of this Matrix this St Matrix we
associate a partition we partition the
coordinates of the row
into sets okay and how do we partition
them according to the identity these are
just going to be the classes of the
identity relation okay so with this if
this is if this row is a vector
Z then um we think uh we just remember
that know Z is going to tell us that the
if coordinate and the J coordinate of uh
of Z are
identical
and then for a given
Matrix here's the information now now
I'm going to tell what are going to be
our types what what are our classes for
are we until 10:30 or yeah okay sorry 10
minutes yeah okay
I you're going to continue so you can
stop yeah I can I I'll just I I'll just
finish uh 10:30 and hopefully it's going
to be like a
re um okay so for a given Matrix a we're
going to remember the following we're
going to remember the partition
associated with each
R and there's also one of thing that I'm
going to need to remember that's going
to be the row span of
a so what do we mean by the row span of
a the row span of a is just a way to uh
to think about uh what are the linear
relations between The Columns of a right
just like note
that uh right for example if uh you know
if I have a
matrix where you know I have three
columns X1 X2 and
X3 and suppose that I have a linear
relation between them for example uh X3
equals um or 2x3 = X1 + X2 okay so
suppose I have such relation then this
is going to be evident in the uh right
so this relation will hold for every row
of this Matrix so this Rel this linear
relation will be uh evident in the row
stem because all if all the rows are
going to have this relation then the
rose span is also going to have uh this
relation okay so so so so so I'm I'm
going to see so so the rose pan is not
going to be like you know in a generic
Matrix the r span will be because these
matrices are are tall and thin in a
generic mat Matrix that the rose pan
would just be um the whole of uh fq to
the L plus one but there are also cases
where I have such relations and then R
span is going to be smaller so so this
is a way to retain that information and
that's going to be important but the
main but but this is really a very small
amount of information because this is
independent of n right the row span is
just a Subspace of fq to the l+ one so
this the amount of information here does
not depend on this does depend on N this
is really I remember a
partition for
each uh
row
okay
[Music]
um and importantly the information I
retained
um is okay so so so these are the okay
so thing of the classes I just defined
right so what do I mean by a type class
say that uh
sorry yeah so what do you mean by a type
class I mean consider you know two
matrices that have the same type so they
have the same list of partitions and
also the same row Stan okay so what I'm
saying is that two matrices that have
even just the same list of
partitions are also ever both are going
to be Witnesses for not being list
decodable or both are not going to be
okay because when I think of the
geometry of the l+1 column of this
Matrix I really only care by identities
I don't care about uh I don't care about
you know the the changing uh the values
as long as I return as long as I retain
the same identity profile right so like
so so so any geometric property for
example is decoding list recoverability
is going to be unaffected by these sort
of changes and that means that um um
yeah that if a matrix is a is a bad uh
is a witness for list decod for non list
decodability then all of its type class
is going to be that okay so in other
words the bad Witnesses for list
decodability can be uh presented as a
union of these classes which is what
what we wanted it's also what we got in
the previous framework okay uh and the
same goes for list recoverability and
all their natural variations in general
let's give a name a local identity
property okay so it's a property which
is local and concered with identities uh
and any such
property uh can be uh expressed as a
union of these type classes and almost
everything I'm going to say uh for the
rest of this talk almost uh is going to
be correct for any local identity
property
okay so just how many types are there
right uh the problem we we started from
was that there were too many types if we
wanted to remember the exact
distributions I'm saying that by going
from remembering distributions to just
remembering these identity
partitions uh the number of types has
dramatically uh decreased uh to a
manageable
level okay so at most you know L todl
equivalence relations uh spefically the
Dell numbers which give us this uh uh
exact quantity but this is a very uh
this is an easy upper
bound uh so how many types are there
okay so you need to remember so so this
is just Q to the l s is just an upper
bound on the number of uh on the on the
number of uh sub subspaces of fq todl
okay so this is going to be the number
of Ro and then this is going to be uh
this is going to be the main part okay
so this is uh the sequence of
partitions um so there
is L to DL or L plus1 to L plus1 but we
remember n of V so it's there's an n as
well um okay and this this number is
Tiny uh why is this a tiny number
because taking Q large enough for
example take Q to be at least L to the L
Epsilon Okay then if we try to measure
this number on an Epsilon basis when
this number is less than Q to the
Epsilon n and q to the Epsilon n is Tiny
because it means that if we you know
change the rate of our code by an
Epsilon fraction then we manage to
overcome this for our Union
bound um and that means that we can
Union bound over the bad types okay and
this is what we wanted I'll just mention
one thing that we could
um know it's it it's
I've even doing something wasteful here
right because I really don't need to
remember the partition of each row I
just need to know the distribution of
the partitions because again I don't
care about permuting the rows but it's
not because it already works here it's
it's not really important to me right
now to to try and do this uh additional
optimization it's easier at least for
the the sake of this presentation to
just think as of us as remembering
exactly the order um of the The Ordering
of the um of the partitions uh uh
associated with the rows and that also
allows us uh to be able to talk about uh
uh properties which are not even
symmetric to uh to coordinate shuffling
if we want I don't know if we do but
this is something we gain by doing that
anyway it's it's more convenient for
this presentation okay so I explained
what are the types that we're going to
use
and next we're going to talk about this
is going to be after the break we're
going to talk about uh how in the
framework of these types we can reason
about this decodability of read Sol
codes thank
you time for a couple of quick
questions not I guess take a break and
continue at
11:00